- I heard your girls in "Bridesmaids"
went to a strip club for research.
- [Rose] Oh yeah.
- Is that true?
- We did, yeah.
Kristen Wiig hired a party
bus or a huge bus, you know
and we all got on and there was like,
a bar and this was pre-COVID obviously,
this was 10 years ago, and we drove, yeah.
We went to the strip club
in LA and it was, yeah.
Most of the women in
the audience were like,
getting married or like bridal parties.
So it was like a lot of that
little like throwing off
like, what do you call it when the like,
you're on a hen's night?
Well, you don't say that
here, bachelorette party?
- A hen's night.
- [Rose] That's what we say in Australia.
- I'm gonna say that from now on.
- A hen's night.
- Yes, all the hens.
- The hens.
So it was hysterical, it was hysterical.
It was a great bonding night
and this was all Kristen Wiig,
you know, she's completely,
she's just so creative
and eccentric and wonderful and loving.
- And what a team building exercise.
- It was very team building exercise.
I got on stage at one point and yeah
but I was wearing a very expensive blouse
and he was very oily.
So it was a little bit
like, oh, this is like,
this costs a lot of money.